das ist der prozess auf dem man hier
sehr lange gewartet hat man dafür nicht
vergessen minneapolis war das ground
zero dieser unruhe nach dem tod von
george iv leute hier hat hier haben
gebäude tagelang gebrannt jetzt möchte
man hier auf nummer sicher gehen und man
sieht hier hinter mir jetzt diesen
maschendrahtzaun
man sieht man sieht auch soldaten
nationalgardisten mit maschinengewehren
man sieht gepanzerte fahrzeuge einen
ganzen karton der herr und um dieses
gerichtsgebäude in der anton minneapolis
gelegt wurde
also man möchte hier tatsächlich
klarstellen dass es hier keine störungen
dieses prozess des jahres gibt wenn man
so möchte eine million dollar wurde hier
alleine an sicherheitsmaßnahmen für die
sicherheitsmassnahmen ausgegeben rund um
dieses gerichtsgebäude
aber der prozess hat eigentlich ein
bisschen mit verwirrung und chaos
begonnen denn eigentlich sollte jetzt ja
bereits die auswahl der geschworenen
hier laufen in minneapolis in diesem
gerichtsgebäude und die wurde vorerst
einmal verschoben
zumindest auf morgen oder vielleicht
noch länger der grund dafür ist dass der
richter entscheiden muss ob es einen
dritten anklagepunkt geben soll gegen
die rektorin den polizisten angeklagt
ist er bereits wegen mordes im in dem
zwei im secondary und auch wegen
totschlag angeblich soll es noch ein
anklagepunkt dazu kommen mord eines
dritten degree das sind alles
verschiedene abstufungen bei der
schwerer dass der straftat so gesehen
ist es ein warten hier in minneapolis
aber die die menschen hier sind
natürlich angespannt weil niemand weiß
genau was in den nächsten tagen und
wochen jetzt hier noch passieren kann
aber peter mandala einschätzung wenn wir
die bilder seit knapp einem jahr immer
wieder vor augen geführt bekommt man
kann sich gar nicht vorstellen dass es
nicht zu einer verurteilung und einer
haten haten haten strafe geben wird
dennoch ließen die immer wieder das ist
tatsächlich möglich dass der polizist
nicht streng streng bestraft wird das
ist eine einschätzung welche strafe wird
es geben und erklären uns einmal ganz
kurz die kann das überhaupt möglich sein
bei solchen bildern dann nicht
verurteilt zu werden
ja in strafgerichtlichen prozessen in
den usa ist natürlich nötig dass es über
jeden zweifel erhaben zu einem
schuldspruch kommt und den entscheiden
natürlich in amerika berühmter weise die
jury die geschworenen und das sind ganz
einfache menschen aus der bevölkerung
die eben hier in den gerichtssaal
geordert werden und das urteil fällen
deshalb muß schluß müssen schlüssige
beweise vorgelegt werden natürlich der
anklage hilft hier das videomaterial das
ja sehr schlüssig ist und sehr eindeutig
allerdings auf der anderen seite die
verteidigung möchte behaupten das kreuz
vor ort in wirklichkeit eigentlich an
einer drogenüberdosis gestorben ist es
wurden in seinem blut hohe werte von
eines eines opiat gefunden das ist die
strategie der verteidigung unter die
verteidigung wird auch sagen dass der
polizist territorien eigentlich den
polizeiprotokollen gefolgt ist denn das
diese taktik am hals eines
festgenommenen zu knien war eigentlich
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt noch samt bei
der polizei in japan ist das hat sich
jetzt natürlich alles geändert
so gesehen insgesamt natürlich ist die
schuld laster so dargelegt dass es
möglicherweise eine verurteilung geben
könnte für die rektorin
zumindest in einen dieser drei oder zwei
anklagepunkte aber sicher ist bei
solchen gerichtsverfahren nichts in den
usa mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bet schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren